Jesus is human and they share common
ancestry so he's human they're human
he's an Israelite they're an Israelite
and they believe in God the father he
believes in God the father so my God and
your God my father and your father
number one notice he doesn't come on
simply say I'm ascending to our father
and our God he could have made it simple
and say that
right yes but notice he makes it clear
he is my father your father my God and
your God I'm explain to you why does
that in a minute but since you quot to
John 20 verse 17 then let's go to John
20 2729 same chapter same chapter
because I'm gonna explain this but I'm
gonna explain it systematically and I'm
gonna explain in the context of the
Bible and not my own opinion but first
of all John 20
27-29 yeah okay read that for
me then he said to Thomas put your
finger here see my hands reach out your
hand and put he's going to say my God
and and he said him I you can't get
around this he said to him not to the
Father the Lord of me and the god of me
and then Jesus rebuke him or bless those
who would make the same confession
without having to see physical
proof so Jesus blessed that confession
right yeah he did yeah okay now
according to the Old Testament an
Israelite only has one Lord and God and
not another go to Psalm 35:23 I'm gonna
answer your question but you got have to
wait if you want a real answer you're
gonna have to wait as I unpack it slowly
but surely okay now Psalm uh Psalm
3523 Psalm
okay uh awake and rise to my defense t
for me my Lord uh my God and Lord my God
and my Lord right yeah okay my God and
my Lord so notice my God and my Lord is
simply in another way saying my Lord and
my God
right now when this was translated into
Greek I'm going to now tell you how the
Greek the Greek now tell me if it sounds
familiar I'm going to use I'm going to
pronounce it theas way
oh the god of me and the Lord of me
right
that's how they Translate in Greek now
John 20:28 Thomas said
ohos same thing the god of me the Lord
of me the Lord of me and the god of me
now Thomas and Israelite could not call
a creature the god of me the Lord of me
the Lord of me the god of me because
that's something that an Israelite can
only say of the true God yet Thomas said
it of Jesus and Jesus accepted it so you
can't just take one verse out of the
chap ignore the rest so it is true the
father is the god of the disciples but
so is Jesus father and son together are
the god of the disciples since the
disciples can't have two gods that means
in some sense Jesus and the father must
be one for both of them to be the god of
the disciples you with me
there yeah okay now so then why did
Jesus say my god well all right let's go
to John 114
let me show
you John 11:4 read that for
me um and the word became flesh and
dwelt among us so you don't deny that as
far as the Gospel of John is concerned
Jesus became flesh
right yes the hypas so Jesus became
flesh but the father didn't become flesh
right yes and the Spirit didn't become
flesh
right indeed yeah and Jesus became flesh
to be the servant of the father I just
want to make that clear right so he came
to become flesh to do the father's will
to be his servant on
Earth yes he submitted he submitted his
human will to his Divine now go to
Jeremiah
32:27 Jeremiah
32:27
Jeremiah Jeremiah what sir 32:27
[Music]
uh I am the Lord the God of all mankind
is anything too hard for me now you're
reading the translation says Mankind in
the Hebrew it's basar literally I the
Lord the God of All
Flesh okay yeah okay now if the father
is Jehovah then he's the God of All
Flesh
right yes and so would Jesus be the God
of All Flesh if he's je so the Holy
Spirit but now if one of the persons
let's just assume the Trinity is true if
one of the becomes flesh and not the
other two and the one who became flesh
did so to be the servant of the father
why would it shock you then that the
father becomes his God after he becomes
flesh I don't know because I just see it
as um then ask what you see I'm asking
you according to the logic of the Bible
I'm talking about biblically not how you
see it because you're not God you don't
know everything and your sight is
Tainted and corrupted by your sin and
your Islamic tradition
I I just I from the scripture like I
just see
um uh God has uh like if you look in the
gospels God has keep going being the
father like Christ has only called God
once or twice what does that got to do
with the fact that besides being called
God he says things and does things that
only God can do even according to your
Quran but that didn't answer my question
notice what you did I gave you the
answer you tapped answer well Jesus is
rarely called God but the father's
called God more often just like Jesus is
often called lord and the father's
rarely called lord does that mean he's
not Lord because he's not called lord as
much as Jesus
is and then you ignored the fact how
many Lord Gods can an Israelite
have uh one but Thomas said to Jesus my
Lord and my god so let's ignore it
because it's not said that often of
Jesus how many times must the Bible say
something for it to be true more than
once yeah that wouldn't make sense right
you got it so now before you bring up
another objection which I'll be more
than happy to answer if we follow
biblical logic not your logic or mine
Jehovah is the God of All Flesh the
father said to be Jehovah the son is
said to be Jehovah the holy spirit said
to be Jehovah yet the son becomes flesh
the father doesn't become flesh the the
spirit doesn't become flesh the son
becomes flesh to be the servant of the
father because he became flesh to serve
the Father the father becomes his God
what's the problem biblically where is
the
problem yeah I think that's why maybe
they would say that they would just
resort to saying the scriptures
corrupted right well they can say what
they want I use the same Gospel of John
who introduces Jesus as the Eternal Word
who's with the father who's God in
essence the Creator and lifegiver who
became flesh so John is consistent with
his own theology if you don't like John
being consistent then stop reading John
because the John John is not a
contextual and it's not unintelligible
like the cron that's all over the
place but I I want to show you something
do you have a cron with
you uh yes okay can you go to chapter 22
of the
Quran chapter 20 through
the right yeah when you can you read
verses six and
[Music]
seven uh that is because Allah alone is
the truth how many are the truth before
you move on how many are the
truth Allah is the AL alone Allah alone
is the truth now keep
reading he alone gives life to the dead
and he alone is most capable of
everything okay so who alone gives life
to the
Dead uh Allah yes now read verse
seven and certainly the hour is coming
there is no doubt about it and Allah
will surely resurrect those in the
graves so pay attention to what your
Quran said Allah alone is the truth he
alone gives life to the dead and the
hours coming Allah will raise them out
of their graves
right yes now go to John
5:21 I know you're going to say you're
going to say these are the words Jesus
says and Jesus going to perform these
actions right okay so now now explain to
me how can Jesus claim the things that
your Quran says only Allah can
do yeah yeah I understand that would
that's why I don't reject the Bible
saying that uh Jesus Is God necessarily
okay it's just that question I had in
mind clear put me back a little bit
right and you also know that's why okay
now so before you ask me another
question so you got it Jesus says just
as the father raises the dead and gives
them life so to the son gives life to
whom he wills and then he says the hour
is coming and it is now when the dead
will hear the voice of the Son of God
and those who hear will live and then he
says the hour is coming when all who are
in their graves will hear his voice and
come out so you you clear and you see
Jesus is claiming the things that even
your cron says only God Almighty not a
creature can claim
right yeah yeah and then also in John
14:6 where Jesus says I am the way and
the truth and the life no one comes to
the father except through me so he's the
truth and he's the life the very things
the Quran says are true of God alone
right yeah so then if Jesus has already
said all that why then would you be
surprised that after the resurrection
when he still flesh with a glorified
body of Flesh that Thomas could then say
my Lord and my god when all throughout
the gospel John the writer is preparing
you for the climax that Jesus has gone
out of his way to show I'm not the
father I'm the father son who's equal to
the father in essence in nature in power
and glory and and ability who also
became man therefore at the climax you
have now Thomas making the full
christological confession that John is
preparing you for all throughout those
chapters that he is the Lord God who
became flesh though he's not the father
and not the Holy
Spirit
yeah uh I don't already have a answer to
this now do you here's a final one I
want to ask you about according to
chapter 57:3 of the Quran
57:3 it says he is the first and the the
last the Inward and the outward and he
knows all things Allah is the first and
last
right yes now you agree that this is
true only of Allah because to be the
first last means you were there from the
beginning with the first of them and
you'll be with the very last generation
of creatures right yes yep that means
Allah's Timeless and eternal right
because for him to be there at the
beginning at the start and for him to
remain till the end that means he's
outside of time the creator of time and
can therefore be with us throughout all
time
right yeah so so and basically first
last means one who's Eternal
right yes okay now I'm gonna read
something for you you
ready yeah I know where you're going
okay so you know that uh when I saw him
I fell at his feet as though dead and he
placed his right hand on me saying do
not be afraid I'm the first and last
that would be Allah
right uh yes it would be yeah ah but
then your Allah in verse 18 says I'm the
living one and I was dead and behold I
live forever more and I hold the keys to
death and Hades so when did your God
Allah die that's Revelation 1
17-8 uh we wouldn't say Allah died but
that's Allah only Allah can say I'm the
first and
last like I said I don't deny that the
gospels and the Epistles and so on uh
portray Christ as as God but that's the
words of Jesus Jesus is claiming that so
you do admit that as far as the new
testament's concerned Jesus claims to be
God Almighty In the
Flesh yes in its lens yes of course okay
good so
then how sharp is Hashim and bringing up
this objection when the objection is
pathetic and easily refuted